foreign
[Music]
news movie and series fans are in for a
treat besides awesome news about
Deadpool 3 we also got updates on blade
as well as Cloverfield and talk about
Kevin feige's statement concerning the
recasting of Chadwick boseman's King
t'challa enjoy our new video
many don't necessarily know the 1998
film blade as a Marvel comic adaptation
but the cult flick definitely has many
fans even today when it was announced
some time ago that mahershava Ali would
play the role of the half vampire and
vampire hunter in a reboot some MCU fans
did express interest in the rather dark
film as The Hollywood Reporter shares
director Bassam Tariq has since departed
from the project however according to
both parties there is no ill will the
reason for The Parting is said to be
various ongoing changes in the
production statements from both sides
sound pretty amicable Cherry considers
it an honor to have been able to
contribute to the project of course the
MCU executives are now desperately
looking for a substitute after all the
movie's release date is already in just
over a year in addition the director
would first have to get to grips with a
semi-finished product that is slowly
Under Pressure there's not much latitude
in the mcu's release calendar as it is
since basically everything Builds on
each other and hangs together journalist
Jeff Snyder even believes to have found
out that the script so far is a mere 90
pages long and hardly includes any
action scenes worth mentioning which is
also said to upset lead actor Ali could
this mean that there will be some
changes regarding Beau de Mayo the
scriptwriter as well
you've gotta hand it to Ryan Reynolds he
simply knows how to Captivate the
audience with his unmistakable style in
a video published on Twitter this
Tuesday he first teases the new Deadpool
3 and ironically shows how much thought
he has put into it only to then casually
announce that Hugh Jackman will return
as Wolverine in the film the latter is
meanwhile walking up the stairs in the
background completely relaxed to the
tune of I Will Always Love You by
Whitney Houston a little joke at the
expense of Jackman's first name further
in the video the two sit together on the
couch and promise to give answers to
many open fan questions with this move
Reynolds has confirmed what has been
suspected for some time still the
announcement came somewhat unexpectedly
and just in typical Reynolds fashion in
one of our Originals last summer we
already reported about the possibility
of a road movie with Deadpool and
Wolverine now upon the request of many
fans this has actually become a reality
this marks Jackman's first return to his
signature role since 2017 when his
original farewell film Logan was
released with Deadpool 3 not only
Deadpool but also Wolverine will from
now on be an official part of the MCU
after they previously belonged to Fox's
X-Men Universe moreover the official
release date has been disclosed which is
scheduled for September 6 2024.
incidentally this year also marks the
50th anniversary of the comic book
character Deadpool who first made his
appearance in The Incredible Hulk issue
number 181 in 1974. an interesting
reaction to Wolverine's parents in
Deadpool 3 came from John Krasinski who
responded to the announcement video with
wait is this our movie we can now
speculate that this has something to do
with krasinski's role as Mr Fantastic in
Fantastic Four a character he also
recently played as an alternate version
in Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of
Madness but whether he will actually
make his return in the upcoming
Fantastic Four or make a way for another
actor is not clear yet at least he is
properly fueled speculations but back to
Deadpool 3 behind the camera free guide
director Sean Levy is in charge of
directing the script is once again being
penned by Deadpool veterans Rhett Rhys
and Paul wernick who have confirmed an R
rating for the film despite its
affiliation with Disney we are
definitely excited to see what the end
product looks like and can't wait for
the release date of September 6 2024.
this November black panther 2 wakanda
forever will be released and the
promotional campaign has long been
underway this week there was a slew of
news about the MCU Sequel and final film
of phase 4 of the MCU Kevin feige for
instance expressed his views on a
possible successor to King t'challa
actor Chadwick Boseman who passed away
in 2020 as he has done in the past he
once again clarified to Empire magazine
that there will be no recasting noting
that the loss is still being coped with
he and director Ryan coogler put a lot
of thought into it as ultimately they
had to pay tribute to Bozeman's life's
work on the one hand and carry on the
story in a meaningful way on the other
so it remains unchanged that Bozeman and
his character will not be replaced but
anything else would have been quite a
surprise this close to release anyway
additional news has emerged regarding
the running time of black panther
wakanda forever according to the
official AMC theater's website the movie
is going to be the second longest MCU
movie to date more precisely it is sent
to run at 2 hours and 41 minutes making
it just under half an hour longer than
its predecessor and about 20 minutes
shorter than Avengers end game which has
been the most extensive MCU film to date
the running time is no doubt Justified
after all with Neymar as the villain and
ironheart as the superhero two new
characters are being introduced at once
to go with the new villain Empire
magazine also shared images of costumes
and characters from the film one of
which features Namor as you can see his
character is strongly based on the
culture of Central America due to the
actions of King t'challa in the first
part Namor sees his kingdom telecon in
danger in addition according to actor
tinakuerta Namor is a mutant just like
in the comics it'll be exciting to find
out what the final result looks like
black panther 2 wakanda forever hits
theaters on November 11th
since the release of 2016's Star Trek
Beyond there have been rumors that an
upcoming Star Trek 4 is in production
this was also confirmed sometime later
however the production of the movie has
always been troubled by delays and crew
changes it was only in August that
director Matt shackman Departed the
project and moved on to Marvel and now
there is even more bad news for Star
Trek fans Paramount Pictures has now
completely removed the movie from its
schedule putting the project on hold
this is yet another setback for the
production in which a JJ Abrams is one
of the people involved the latter had
held out the prospect of a shooting
start at the end of 2022 earlier this
year however back then things were
looking very different now not only is
the project lacking a director but also
a release date deadline has learned that
the movie may not be canceled rather
they are still looking for a suitable
director the production of Star Trek 4
therefore remains interesting although
the signs are not pointing towards an
end of the franchise what will happen
next is still unclear for the time being
after a long period of Silence a new
addition to the cast of Beverly Hills
Cop Axel Foley was announced a few days
ago in addition to lead actor Eddie
Murphy who was celebrating his return as
the eponymous detective Foley former
Hollywood star Kevin Bacon is now part
of the cast as well in addition to him
there are already a number of other
co-stars joining the now fourth film
among the returning actors is Judge
Reinhold as sergeant Billy Rosewood
Axel's former partner in Beverly Hills
Police Department also after nearly
35-year Hiatus Paul Reiser rejoins the
cast as detective Jeffrey Freeman to
play Axel's partner two other attorneys
are John Ashton as Sergeant John Taggart
and Bronson Pinchot as the flamboyant
art salesman Sergey in still unknown
roles we will see alongside Kevin Bacon
Gray's Anatomy actress Taylor Page lost
star Mark Pellegrino and Snowden actor
Joseph Gordon-Levitt thus who among the
cast members will possibly appear as the
antagonist to Axel Foley is still
unclear overall the cast is very
pleasing for fans of the film series
which is why many are now eagerly
awaiting further information a release
date is sadly still pending but we will
keep you up to date as always
with Cloverfield director Matt Reeves
pulled off a real surprise hit in 2008
the found footage style monster film
revolves around a massive monster that
haunts New York City two sequels also
came out that were only Loosely related
to the original but the last installment
being released in theaters in 2018. now
Paramount Pictures is apparently
planning another sequel as deadline
reports the ritual author Joe Barton is
said to be writing the script while
under the shadow director babak and Vari
is set to direct the film one returnee
behind the camera is JJ Abrams who has
been a producer on all three films so
far the period in which the movie is
based and whether this time there will
possibly be a link to one of the
previous movies is not yet known but it
is also possible that the upcoming
feature will be a standalone film again
following the previous concept a Common
Thread will surely be a gigantic monster
From Another Dimension once again so far
the exact story has always been kept
secret until close to release so you
should not expect any news on the plot
anytime soon we are nevertheless looking
forward to more updates regarding the
cast and filming a release date has not
been announced yet
that was the news for this week for
those of you who still want to watch
more check out our new Original Episode
for Mufasa The Lion King to learn
everything we know so far about the
future film if you like our videos feel
free to leave a thumbs up and share your
thoughts in the comments
[Music]